greetings friends I am Palma we have  much work ahead of us but maybe it can  even be fun if you choo-choo to operate  that is I get out of there fast about  with you come on you got run need to get  to my secret lair get off the bridge  maybe it's not getting through to you  but Alma is dangerous I must say that  woman it's been a most intrusive mission  so far  so I can have almost finished building  our new painted portal and then I will  make all other world beautiful yay  let's go wreck the heck out of pom  technology is so awesome  and you look so awesome while using it I  assure you  game over heavy resistance is not useful  over I'm just getting started  termination sequence activated  Jessie  you our only hope